so director david ayer's been making
some moves lately that really makes it
seem like he is hoping to drum up
a release the snyder cut style campaign
for an
air cut of his original suicide squad
film from 2016.
now given what happened with the snyder
cut this is not super surprising but
it's also kind of weird for a few
reasons
firstly part of the reason snyder was
able to drum up so much support was
because
the cut that was released of justice
league was so vastly different from his
own previous film that it was very clear
that had been heavily tampered with and
moved far away from his original vision
that's not quite the case with suicide
squad now suicide squad was
heavily re-shot and went through a lot
of messes in the editing phase
however between ar only being given six
weeks to write the thing and admitting
that there was interference even at the
writing stage
it's hard to imagine that there was an
unblemished version of this thing that
even
really existed before it reached the
edit plus the word is there's nearly an
hour of cut footage would you just
put it all back in a three hour suicide
squad movie
it just feels to me like ayer is banking
on more goodwill than he actually has